bonsoir à rené sébastien bauer merci
d'être avec nous alors on voit que là il
ya quand même de la grogne en allemagne
face aux mesures de restriction wii no
run l'allemagne est aujourd'hui dans une
situation un peu comparable à celle de
la france il y a deux mois on a pris un
peu de retard par rapport aux mesures
qu'il fallait prendre mais finalement la
situation n'est pas tellement différente
de celle de la france
nous avons aujourd'hui quand même les
premiers effets positifs des mesures qui
ont été prises depuis dix jours le
chiffre de réinfection est quand même
nettement inférieur aujourd'hui d'après
les chiffres actuels il est de 0,5 et
quelques
donc oui on est dans un problème
européen et les problèmes sont à peu
près les mêmes qu'en france ce que vient
de dire mon prédécesseur pour la région
rhône alpes c'est vrai ici il ya
également des couacs pour les problèmes
de réfrigération des des piqûres à faire
est de dire que je ne suis plus en
france rené sébastien bauer
non non vous suis très très bien juste
cette question sur la nouvelle souche
mutante qui serait présente dans votre
temps en allemagne depuis le mois de
novembre
quels sont vos connaissances sur ce
virus mutant sur sa progression c'est
fâcheux parce que ce qui me manque c'est
une régulation européenne pour
déterminer les critères et les
statistiques
l'allemagne a un seul laboratoire
capable de classifier le virus qui est à
l'hôpital de charité à berlin
donc très probablement on a pendant
longtemps on a pas
enregistré le fait que cette nouvelle
mutation du coronavirus a déjà était
présente et c'est très dommage parce
qu'évidemment cela empêche les
différents pays de prendre les mesures
adéquates
on aurait probablement pu se passer de
la fermeture des frontières vis-à-vis de
la grande-bretagne et parce que de
l'autre côté
le problème aurait été le même vous
pensez que vous pensez que la présence
de cette souche mutante sur le sol
allemand depuis assez longtemps
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines
elle est responsable de prêt pourrait
être responsable de la situation
épidémique en rebond c'est tout à fait
spéculatifs les résultats des examens ne
sont pas encore définis nous le savons
ofas on peut il penser ne s'est pas
garanti je crois que le fait essentiel
c'est la discipline des gens qui
commencent en avoir marre de toute cette
affaire qui diminue surtout chez les
jeunes c'est très difficile il faut bien
se rendre compte que l'allemagne est
entourée de pays voisins alors que la
france quand même beaucoup de frontières
maritimes les poissons de l'atlantique
de son propre comptage yeux ça change a
pu les données mais sur le plan global
global
la france est dans le mail petra que
l'allemagne
et que pensez-vous dé la gestion de
cette crise par la chancelière angela
merkel il ya des mesures de restriction
qui ont été prises à la mi décembre dont
un confinement partiel qui sera effectif
au moins jusqu'au 10 janvier
ce que son ami ni décembre à ce que
c'était trop tard dit selon vous c'était
probablement trop tardif de réagir
maintenant il faut voir que l'allemagne
est un pays fédéral c'est-à-dire la
chancelière n'a pas les mêmes moyens
qu'un président de la république en
france pour prendre les décisions les
décisions se prennent au niveau des
länder et là il ya eu des réticences
évidemment il ya des länder qui sont
bien moins touché surtout dans le nord
et qu'ils n'ont pas envie de prendre les
mêmes décisions tout aussi stricte que
la bavière audace axe alors vous faisait
tout à leur addition justement la
vaccination le rythme de cette campagne
de vaccination en allemagne
c'est un peu similaire à sif paf en
france comment se déroule tel un peu de
la même façon il y adéquat oakenfold
s'attendre on peut pas toujours faire
des reproches
l'administration c'est une situation
tout à fait nouvelle et il faudra avoir
un peu de patience
de toute façon ça prendra probablement
plusieurs mois pour avoir un effet sur
le nombre de cas installer et sur le
nombre de décès mais vous pensez que en
allemagne il peut y avoir un changement
de stratégie dans la manière de mener
cette campagne de vaccination et et de m
peut-être que les autorités vont mettre
un coup d'accélérateur élargir cette
campagne non parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de limitations techniques qui est
qu'ils sont insurmontables lacourte
encore un court terme et c'est le
maillot des transports c'est la
production c'est lille
l'instrumentation nécessaire merci merci
à vous merci avoue rené sébastien bauer
prenez soin de vous vous êtes un petit
peu malade médecin spécialiste en
chirurgie générale et expertises
médicales merci pour cet éclairage